[Musica]
questa è la tempesta uno dei quadri più
importanti della storia dell'arte è
anche uno dei più misteriosi come il suo
autore il giorgione da castelfranco
veneto artista tanto enigmatico quanto
leggendario che già in vita
vedo una svolta epocale alla pittura e
quest'opera per molti storici e
considerata il punto di non ritorno
l'opera che anticipò i tempi verso la
maniera moderna probabilmente
quest'opera è stata dipinta fa poche
centinaia di metri da qua vi basti
pensare che tra il 400 e il 500 italiano
assieme a leonardo michelangelo tiziano
raffaello il giorgione diede il via a
quel progresso figurativo che ancora
oggi spinge gli artisti di tutto il
mondo alla ricerca della perfezione
facciamo ora un salto temporale e
andiamo in francia dove troviamo vincent
van gogh nel 1890 seduti in un campo di
grano intento a dipingere quello che
sarà considerato un nuovo progresso
figurativo anche in quest'opera vediamo
una tempesta figurativamente
concettualmente diversa da quella del
giorgione il giorgione con il quadro
rappresenta un'allegoria misteriosa van
gogh il suo quadro non rappresenta è e
quest'opera è considerata il punto di
non ritorno
l'opera che anticipò i tempi la prima
opera d arte contemporanea
ovviamente non sono gli unici ad aver
affrontato ho rappresentato una tempesta
uno tsunami un diluvio universale ma
quasi tutti gli artisti che hanno
affrontato questo tema
non lo hanno fatto una volta raggiunta
la maturità artistica lo hanno fatto da
giovani maturi il giorgione aveva 24
anni quando dipinse la tempesta per i
non giovani shakespeare scrisse la
tempesta ha 46 anni ma non sono qui per
tenere una lezione di storia dell'arte o
fare le previsioni del meteo sono qui
per condividere un osservazione
molti di noi
durante la nostra giornata professionale
facciamo brainstorming cervelli in
tempesta
sappiamo tutti che una tecnica creativa
di gruppo si parte da un problema ci si
concede la massima libertà propositiva
senza censure alla ricerca di soluzioni
e nuove idee in gruppo quindi ma tutto
questo gli artisti lo fanno da soli come
osservando la quiete prima della
tempesta
la loro urgenza creativa non gli
permette di aspettare che qualcuno vi
sottopongo un problema per trovare una
soluzione e tantomeno proporre idee
sulla base di un esigenza gli artisti
anticipano tempestivamente ma attenzione
e tempestività non è sinonimo di
velocità non significa arrivare primi
significa arrivare prima perché più
veloci andiamo e più tempo perdiamo
quest'epoca è caratterizzata dalla
velocità noi per la velocità
sacrifichiamo la qualità sotto tutti i
suoi aspetti
basti pensare al mondo di facebook fatto
è meglio che perfetto ma è proprio nel
come facciamo le cose che risiede il
perché le facciamo certo cercare la
perfezione opporsi obiettivi
raggiungibili può essere frustrante ma
io non mi riferisco a questo mi
riferisco a come facevano il pane le
norme e al per
che lo facevano cose perché lo facevano
per noi
e permettetemi lo facevano sempre al
momento giusto cioè tempestivamente
questo è il sinonimo da ricercare quindi
per comprendere meglio il significato di
tempestività
proviamo ad analizzare il significato di
tempesta che cos'è una tempesta una
tempesta è un qualunque stato disturbato
di un corpo celeste
wow prima al buffet nel contratti un
paio di disturbati li vedo anche in sala
ma come si forma una tempesta una
tempesta si sviluppa intorno alla
combinazione di forze opposte che
producono vortici acque e diavoli di
sabbia
quindi vuol dire che prima della
tempesta
c'è calma piatta quiete noi a tutto
questo gli artisti ce l'hanno dentro le
forze opposte il corpo celeste i vortici
diavoli il disturbo il buffet e anche la
calma piatta la quiete e la noia
sì la noia perché vedete per osservare
il mondo come fanno gli artisti
bisogna avere una grande capacità di
annoiarsi
perché solo annoiandosi del mondo sia la
possibilità di creare il proprio mondo
dobbiamo comprendere che non possiamo
coprire tutti i buchi dove ci sarebbe la
noia soprattutto coi bambini perché è
dalla noia che nasce il gioco e
credetemi non c'è niente di più serio
del gioco di un bambino e anche dei
grandi
la noia
è l'alleato principale per creare una
tempesta la noia il punto preciso tra la
realtà e la fantasia perché dalle
tempeste si fugge come dalla noia certo
per me è facile parlare di noia vengo
dalla provincia friulana
vi racconto questa qualche anno fa mi
trovavo a napoli con due amici fabio e
paolo ne situazione classica
parcheggiamo la macchina vicino al
maschio angioino
diamo 10 euro ragazzo intanto che
chiediamo dove possiamo andare a cenare
si avvicina un po di gente un certo
punto un uomo di mezza età ci guarda e
ci chiede di dove siamo di udine
rispondiamo noi a lui ho fatto il
militare a palmanova
noi siamo di codroipo quando volevo
annoiarli veramente dei vivo a codroipo
vedete noi e tempestività uguale una
tempesta di risate quindi questo non
vale solo per gli artisti o per i
parcheggiatori abusivi
mi spiego meglio
c'era una volta un signore annoiato che
passeggiava perso nei suoi pensieri
ad un certo punto fu attirata da degli
schiamazzi provenienti da un cortile si
fermò a vedere dei bambini giocare a
biglie notò che queste sfere passando
attraverso una pozzanghera uscendo
lasciavano una riga di fango siamo a
budapest nel 1938 e quel signore era la
slow vero
l'inventore della penna a sfera un
giornalista al punto preciso tra la
realtà e la fantasia può diventare un
inventore laurie anderson è una delle
artiste che stimo di più
musicista pittrice scrittrice artista
multimediale si definisce semplicemente
una narratrice di storia nel 2003 le fu
chiesto di entrare a far parte al primo
programma all'interno della nasa fu
residente alla nasa per due anni le tn
chiesto di vivere a stretto contatto con
gli scienziati intervistata alla fine di
questa esperienza dichiarò programmi
come questo dovrebbero essere ovunque un
artista vede le cose da un punto di
vista unico e solitario come gli
astronauti anche lei affronterà il tema
della tempesta vi leggo un estratto
dalla sua canzone
la tempesta continua a soffiare l'angelo
indietro nel futuro e questa tempesta è
chiamata progresso andy warhol disse che
in futuro
ognuno di noi fa il mondo sarà famoso
per 15 minuti
beh qua me ne hanno dati solo 8 per cui
vado a concludere ogni volta che studio
gli artisti
capisco che la tempesta ha un grande
lato positivo e cioè il nuovo e il nuovo
ha bisogno di sostenitori deciderete da
soli come affrontare questa tempesta
moderna che vi attende
e sarà una cosa bellissima se la sapete
affrontare con la giusta dose di noia
adesso vi chiederete cosa c'entra il
giorgione con la nasa beh ditemelo voi
io speravo solo di annoiarvi veramente
grazie
[Musica]